ce samedi 22 avril aura lieu l'opération
ge achète un livre pays
une manifestation qui vise à valoriser
la production locale
rennes mais le bon et auteure elle a
toujours aimé écrire mais a rencontré de
nombreuses difficultés pour éditer son
livre j'ai toujours écrit dans ma vie
enfin monde mais je ne tombait pas la
façon de les faire éditer la façon de
réaliser mon rêve que c'était une ferme
locale
et puis dans une année nous avons le pas
je me suis retrouvé à côté d'une
bibliothécaire de sa nounou qui m'a
donné la marche à suivre donc la semaine
suivante je suis allé la voir
c'est arrivé peut-être départ d'un
talent saint denis et jacques brenner de
donner le nom des grenades
d'après l'un des éditeurs mais surtout
elle m'a présenté à au dépôt légal
le dépôt légal mesure parfois
obligatoire visant à ce que les auteurs
fournissent une copie de leurs oeuvres à
un organisme qui en assurent le contrôle
on est les seuls à la réunion avant le
dépôt légal
il ya une convention qui a été signée
depuis 2005 entre la bnf bibliothèque
nationale de france et le département
pour voilà cette mission de conservation
tout ce qui est publié
édité à la réunion soit à la plata
départemental et aussi à la bibliothèque
nationale de france grâce à la
bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion raide mais le bon enfin pu faire
éditer son premier livre intitulé
patchwork de vie c'est ici que je suis
venu pour trouver les renseignements
qu'il me fallait pour faire éditer mon
livre mon premier livre et j'ai donc
fait des démarches auprès du dépôt légal
d'amour m'installant était très gentil
ma
donnez toutes les démarches à suivre
pour arriver à dépasser pour aider à
passer du prototype à mon livre ce
samedi 22 avril une présentation de
l'édition réunionnaise aura lieu à la
bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion ainsi que des échanges avec des
éditeurs
[Musique]